hello hello
hello
what up Casey Sports nerd farad L Sam
Carson what's going on
everyone yes billyb entertainment sounds
like we are getting the Madam web
trailer on
Monday uh YouTube doesn't say that I'm
streaming right now which is
interesting very interesting how am I
supposed to
uh
huh
huh what's up everyone how's it
going this is a good episode tonight
it's I I think everyone's really gonna
like
it really soor I'm having some technical
problems right
now
why isn't
it I mean it seems to be working yo what
up Jimmy thanks for that Super Chat man
what's going
on good to see you ready for Loki have
you watched the uh have you been
watching
it hey thanks Jason appreciate that
what's going on Matthew what's going on
everyone husam what do I think the new
Avengers team members are uh I think I
think we know a decent amount of them I
think we you know have Captain America
Sam Wilson's Captain America who's going
to lead it um I think chok's going to be
on it hoping regular Hulk's gonna be on
it
um
Spider-Man Captain Marvel Daredevil doct
strange I don't think they're going to
really in introduce many more new
characters who are going to be on it I I
kind of hope they do
but we'll see we'll see
I think all I think a lot of the new
stuff's going to come as far as like
variant cameos are speaking of which
today we are introduced to uh Victor
timely I'm curious to see what everyone
thinks about this character I I think
this episode is great and then episode
four next week is
like some of the best for Marvel that
I've seen ever so I'm excited for next
week with this episode's fantastic as
well good Jimmy glad
Shan Chi too yes yes Shan Chi Shan Chi
for sure and I think Wong actually is
going to be a pretty play play a pretty
decent role moving forward as he should
this thing isn't telling me I'm live
which is really weird but we clearly are
so I'm not gonna fight
it wonder if I no it still
says
whatever I mean I hope there'll be at
him Amazing Spider-Man 3 but who knows I
think Andrew Garfield uh I think he
would love to come back especially after
the love that he has received after uh
Spider-Man no way home for sure uh does
the pace pick up yeah yeah the I I uh
episode two was the slowest episode
episode two was the slowest episode um
this this episode definitely the pace
picks up and then like four it's
like pretty int I think I I think
they're all pretty intense even last
episode was pretty
intense like with the the torture scene
that's not the last you'll see of that
device by the way but yeah Kevin or Miss
minutes who do you think has greater
power
um Miss
minut I mean Kevin F for real
though but as far as like an AI
yeah just my opinion what's going on man
good to see you back in here thanks for
stopping by again hope you're doing all
right uh do I think Peter B Parker will
have a bigger role in beond the
spiderverse yeah I do yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah do I think Black Knight or
moonnight might be a part of the new
Avengers I would love for moonight to be
a part of the new Avengers I don't think
Black Knight I don't know if they and
excuse me I'm I'm sick so if you hear me
coughing a lot sorry but I don't think
black I don't think Marvel studos really
has that
many like I don't know how complete
their plans are for Black Knight I know
kit Harrington's supposed to come in and
I know they teased him in the Eternal
suppos credit scene but he's not
supposed to appear in Blade but they are
rewriting that script again so maybe he
is now but I heard he's not supposed to
be a part of Blade so
like oh I don't know where they plan to
put him but we do know the Supernatural
set's coming so I'm excited I'm excited
to see what they do with that side
because I really liked werewolf by night
and I don't typically like stuff like
that but I think it was done really well
I actually like the fact that it was
black and white I know the the color
full color scheme is coming out for it
so we'll see but uh yeah
uh Carson Reed would I rather have the
six short episode series or more
long-term Marvel
series I mean I think Loki I think this
I think this is long term and oh you
know what you're probably talking about
like Daredevil being like 18 episodes
um I actually think 18 episodes is
really long but from what I've heard it
was going to be split in half
Nine episodes for a season 1 a and then
Nine episodes for a season 1B which is
basically two seasons so I would rather
and there and they were going to put
them like six months apart so it's
basically like two seasons except you
don't have to wait a few years to get
the next season so I would rather have
like nine episodes that are like 40 45
minutes
long and then have like the completion
of of a season tie into something else
and then like come back that's what I
would rather have cuz I feel like 18
like to to
watch like specifically speaking about
Marvel right because you know like I
watch The Big Bang Theory uh I'm
rewatching that right now because I love
that show and it's like 12 Seasons long
and you know 20 something episodes in a
season like that's fine for like a show
like that but for something in the MCU
that's connected and everything like
that like I think you should give it
enough time
like nine episodes but also wrap it up
and connect it to something else because
that's what the MCU
is so yeah did Wonderman get scrapped
you know I've heard conflicting reports
about
that we'll just have to wait and see in
all honesty I I I actually don't know
the answer to that sorry yeah let me
check on this YouTube thing one more
time it still doesn't say
huh
weird I mean we're clearly live
so I won't fight it I guess let me check
on YouTube
here um you really do you guys think
they should drop Seasons all at once you
guys really think so hey what's up
Anthony how's it going man I see you
there what's going on
um you guys think they should drop
everything at once I don't know we'll
see with
Echo I'm not really
sure
because like I watch a lot of like
Netflix like I watch a lot of kramas and
I I actually really can't stand when
they're not all dropped at once so I
feel you but I also think like it raises
a lot of
excitement when you don't get it all at
once because then we can discuss around
each episode which is what we do you
know so I don't know I don't like
waiting but I like I like the excitement
and the hype it builds
up you know
so
okay I mean we seem to have no problems
here with the stream so I'm just going
to ignore the fact that YouTube on my
back and says I'm not
streaming so
yeah who's my favorite Spider-Man Aiden
um you know I I've said this a couple
times
but I grew up with Toby McGuire is my
Spider-Man and he's my Spider-Man like
really I have like zero against the
other Spider-Man I love Andrew I love
Tom and I I well one I think Andrew got
way more hate than he
deserved the Spider-Man movie The
Amazing Spider-Man movies being how they
were was not his fault at all he he was
fantastic and and Tom is fantastic I
mean I love them all but my childhood is
like Hugh Jackman Wolverine Toby McGuire
Spider-Man and you know just just
watching the you know
Spider-Man and his friends growing up
you know the aan anim man you know it's
just you know the Avengers I just I
watched all that growing
up that's my childhood so Toby is really
my Spider-Man uh Bucky Barnes thank you
Joe what's going on please hit the like
button woof woof yes thank you for that
Super Chat Mr Anderson what is up thanks
for being here Ryan Nome new some got it
thank you for that Super Chat don't know
if I touched on it what's your thoughts
on bri Larson moving from Miss Marvel
yeah yeah so I mentioned it in the video
I
did I definitely think that she gets way
more hate than she deserves I I get how
she rubs some people the wrong way a
little bit and those promotions and
stuff like that but man I hate that
she's gotten so much hate I actually
really like Brie Larson as an actress um
and I and I like her as Captain Marvel
um I hope she stays but we'll
see uh somebody was asking me something
and asked me a few times boobo the
bearded dragon uh yeah he's in this
episode a lot Victor timley is in this
episode a lot oh wait a second Oh no
just kidding uh Victor Victor Tomley is
in this episode a lot it's pretty much
all about him and I'm curious to see
what people think about him in in this
episode I really am
curious very very very very
curious uh Jaden that sucks man oh
bummer
oh we just got to save up money
man fortunately that's all you can do
sometimes I've been there and I've had
to do it you
know Kim you think that King Dynasty is
going to be a global Invasion but King
variant and Earth must have multiple
hero groups like new Avengers Young
Avengers Fantastic Four street level
what do you
think I that's how I picture it it and
then I think they fail I think they lose
and then I think
uh I don't know how Loki season two ends
but I think the reports of the TVA kind
of saving people I I hope that's
accurate I really hope that's accurate
so I think the Avengers might lose and
then TVA might show up and kind of like
save them and then the universe actually
gets destroyed I would love that like
honestly that's what I want to happen I
really want that to happen because we
know they're going to lose right you you
don't have like the King Dynasty and
then Secret Wars like you don't have
them beat Kang or if they do it's just
like you know one variant they're not
going to beat like the Kang
Trio and and they shouldn't to establish
the huge like that was why ingame was
so
good and so was Infinity war is because
you saw Thanos basically as this
unbeatable guy right that's what made it
so good so I think the same should be
that's why I didn't really like the D
ction they took Quantum Mania I really
hate that one they defeated Kang and two
they defeated him with an army of ants
like I just I hated that it just doesn't
make sense to me so
um I think they should establish King as
just this guy that can't be beat
especially with all his variants and I
think that's what should happen in King
Dynasty so yeah the Star Wars collector
what's up you were here last week
welcome back Emma welcome back as well
hello everybody Welcome everybody back
uh yeah Javier I've heard that as well
excuse me um heard that as
well where' your comment go yes that the
Vision Quest is no longer happening it
turns Children's Crusade we'll have to
wait and see them about that um what's
really weird is
like there's a lot of these Marvel shows
that like Marvel has never really talked
about like we've got the castings for
them and stuff like that but they've
never talked about them so it's really
weird um hearing you know
like the inside reports when we don't
really know much about them
so yeah yeah hello Sean hello the
beat uh yeah blue Spartan I don't know
about Ant-Man dying it certainly would
have established Kang as someone
serious um but even
if I just think that somehow the
combined
powers
of Hank p as Ant-Man Scott Lang as
Ant-Man Janet vany as the wasp and uh
hope as the wasp and then of course his
daughter stature uh I think they them
them combined as a team fighting King
but destroying his technology that's how
he should have been defeated and then he
should have gotten out of the quantum
realm while maybe Ant-Man and them got
locked in I I think that would have been
a better
ending and then they got out
somehow
I hate that he was killed I hate that he
was defeated by ants and then the Kang
Trio post credit scene you could have
easily have just went so the king that
we exiled
escaped you
know they they you could have easily
done
that so
easy easy easy easy who would you want
to voice Galactus you know
they we've we've seen the fan castings
and I
like uh who was the Antonio Banderas I
actually like that one but from the
beginning we've heard Liam niss and I'm
like
yeah that'd be pretty dope or
like I don't know how it would feel if
like Morgan Freeman vo galatis I like
Morgan Freeman's voice so I don't know
if I'd want him to play galatis but I
think Liam niss or Antonio Bas would
both be solid be
solid Ryan thanks for another Super Chat
uh with news you get from Marvel DC does
some stuff for your entertainment
expectations uh the movies you most no
actually no that's a good question um I
get asked this every now and then by
like my close friends no I'm a guy who
really likes to know what's going
on and to me and I've actually like had
this talk with Disney before when
they're like you know we don't want any
spoilers coming out because we want we
don't want people to know what's going
to happen and I'm like well there's I
think there's a certain excitement that
comes with that of knowing and not but
still not knowing what's actually going
to happen because you could hear inside
stuff all day long until you actually
see the movie you still don't know
what's going to happen right like unless
you get actual leaked version of the
movie you really don't know what's going
to happen so even with Spider-Man no way
home
like I was I always say this like I
based off of what I've been told the
things that I saw beforehand even stuff
that I saw that I couldn't post about or
talk about like I was
99% sure that they were going to be in
the movie so it's
like that 1% actually one made me
nervous because I did so many videos
about it made me nervous
but at the same time I was like are they
are they are they are they are they
going to be in it are they going to be
in it and it like made me so excited and
since I was like I was like on the edge
of my seat waiting for it to happen when
it did happen I would I think in my
personal opinion that I was that the
moment itself was so much better because
of that anticipation than if I was just
sitting in the theater and I had no idea
that Andrew and Toby were going to show
up I think if I was sitting there I
would have been excited but I wouldn't
it wouldn't have
felt as good cuz I would have been
like no way they brought back Toby
McGuire whereas like in the theater I
was like come on come on come on and
then that scene came I was like oh my
gosh this is it this is it and then they
came on screen I was like yeah like I
was like freaking out and everybody was
freaking out you know what I mean and I
feel like that's I feel like that's a
bigger reaction because
everybody everybody was expecting it but
wasn't 100% sure that it was going to
happen even if you doubted it 1% you
still weren't 100% sure so to me that's
how I feel about a lot of this stuff I
love going in like oh I heard this blah
blah blah blah but I want to see it play
out and it might not play out and either
way I'm like oh they went a different
way or I'm like oh this is what
happened you know that's just kind of
how it
is uh don't spam guys please don't spam
the mods are gonna get
you Matthew have a good weekend
yes I do remember Mr Anderson uh ke re
was room for
galatis his voice would work too in all
honesty
yeah ah Jose nice you're at the gym nice
nice yeah so Ryan
I hope that answers a question very
in-depth answer just give
there I don't know that that's just
that's just me though like do how do you
guys feel about leaks right hey what's
up Brandon yo what's going on how do you
guys feel about leaks you
know guys you guys like leaks you
know I think I think a lot of you know I
built my my early fan base for the
channel based on
leaks yeah and I do I wish I could still
talk about them yeah but I ain't trying
to get sued by Disney either by Marvel
and
Disney hey you got yours I'm so glad
awesome yeah they're not bad right I
mean they feel pretty good Chien bird
hey thanks so much for that Super Chat
let um Atman defeated King but didn't
kill him King just got smaller than
before yeah and you know what and I also
do agree with that as well but I still
hate even if we're going to use the word
defeated I still hate that he was
defeated by the army of
ants like I feel like you're teasing
your big
bad and that just like
it makes him seem smaller not like you
were talking about but it just doesn't
make him seem as intense as Thanos right
we never saw Thanos got de get
defeated hold
on sorry we never saw Thanos got
defeated get
defeated sorry I'm a little sick still
guys my voice is kind of
horse Sean that's that's a good way to
put it that's a good way to put it Sean
you love the leaks just don't want
spoilers because there is a difference
right with the leaks it is that I don't
know right I don't know if it's real
blah blah blah blah blah and I remember
for Avengers endgame there was like a
legit leaked footage shots that came out
and I did not look at them and people
are like this is like the stuff you post
about why aren't you posting about this
I'm like because that is a legit imate
spoiler right it's like a legitimate
thing and for endgame I didn't want to
see it I saw the stuff for U Multiverse
of Madness like there was the the the
Illuminati picture got leaked I saw that
I'm like sweet cool the Illuminati
awesome but um for ingame I didn't want
it I didn't want to know anything about
ingame you
know that was like so
big so
big
I'm turning into a zombie I really hope
not yeah I just don't think I just don't
think that was a good creative writing
decision I don't think he should have
got defeated by ants I think it should
have been like all of the Lang
family SL vany family together like and
PIM Family um they should have all been
like attacking King but attacking like
his base as well not just him right so
like shut down his Tech I think that
would have been a better way to do it
but I don't know hire me Marvel you guys
watching like I'll help you
write I write Marvel videos literally
every day I bet you I could help a
little bit I didn't go to school for it
but I do have a a bachelor's degree
so my English literature is
[Laughter]
decent hey thanks the star collector I
appreciate that hello Allan De La Cruz
what's going on Adam the Marvel man what
do you think is better Guardians through
your no way home uh no way home but
again I've said this a few times I don't
like half
cyborg human things half robotic human
things like any type of like half human
half Android thing just like freaks me
out and just gives me the chill so I
Guardian story kind of rubb me wrong way
that way cuz it was kind of painful for
me to watch so no way home yeah no way
home is like for me I know some people
like a it's too fan service blah blah
blah no I I love it
man give me that like I love it uh this
episode duration Billy buug
entertainment um it's
like 50 something minutes with the
credits here hold
on got the ones Disney sent
me
what I'm I might not have access to it
anymore okay hold
on so it's a so with the credits it's
about 53 minutes long that's what I have
here yeah like a tiny bit over 53
minutes long but the credits probably
start at like 45
minutes 40 here I can tell you right now
the credit
[Music]
start right here I believe at the
scene
the credits start at like 48
minutes 49
minutes they end on a they end on a go
yeah so the the credit started like 48
minutes 50 seconds
so
yeah ohello hello back to South Africa
hello hello hey we're getting a lot more
people in the chat now what's going on
everybody yeah fishing works I I would
actually really like to see that I'd
like to see like maybe a Venom movie
with him in it actually kind of hope
that like
uh I
hope I hope the venom venom 3 has
Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield I say
that reserving L because I would like it
to be Tom as well but I feel like Andrew
should get a chance to fight an alien
like he said in no way home
right uh there's not 20 minutes of foot
uh credits this time there's five
minutes of credits this time but yeah no
I feel you though like there's there's
there's some times that are it's like
hot dang like it's a long time for
credits got about nine minutes here
y'all if yall need to get up use the
bathroom do all that stuff be sure to
get it
done I'm going to start to pull up my
stuff here let pull up Disney
plus Mr Anderson is probably going to
take me a little bit to do my freaking
timer like I did last time I don't even
remember how I did it I think I kind of
remember how I did it wait let me
think because I think
I I think I remember how it worked yeah
yeah I kind of think I remember how I
did
it
maybe Galaxy gigs I think I missed
something else you said because it looks
like you're replying to somebody
else thoughts on why it seems Loki isn't
trending none of our reactions a dum at
all yeah you know I I I looked back on
season one and you know I was trending
many times too uh many of my breakdowns
were trending for Loki and I don't know
man I I I do think the superhero fatigue
and and specifically right now Marvel
fatigue is very real for some people
like I'm a God I could watch anything
and be pretty happy like in all honesty
like it it takes so much for me to truly
dislike
something uh it it really does for
Marvel I'm a little bit pickier when
when like She-Hulk like I don't think
She-Hulk was bad by any means but I I
didn't like
the sitcom style of it because it's just
not what Marvel does Grant and I know
they're trying to Branch out and do
different things but it didn't work for
me I would have rather had something
that was very connected right the story
included like the story wasn't that much
connected with itself it was here and
there so I don't know I think some I I
think some people are just having a hard
time with with Marvel recently which I
can understand I get
it uh Robert Breeze 2 that's a good
question do I think YouTube media has
hurt Marvel with their negative reviews
of criticism sometimes unjustified over
the past few years years I I will say
that I've seen things like I've seen
videos like crapping on bri Larson and
it's
undeserved and it's also like like I've
met a lot of celebrities now at this
point in my career I can't say I know
them so I know these other people who
have never met them don't know them
either
right I do think there's a lot of unfair
assumptions and people acting like they
know who these actors truly
are and and stating that as fact right
I've seen a lot of people say a lot of
stuff about Brie Larson like their her
freaking nextdoor neighbor and know
everything about her I think those
things can be
harmful
um I really do and I W I
wish I don't
know I don't know how much they would
affect because how how many people are
going to going to see that and then
still see the movie you know what I mean
like what I think is and I know for a
fact that Disney values this and Kevin
FY himself values this as well Rotten
Tomato scores are
big they really are they're really big
so I think you know if something gets a
good Rotten Tomato score it it it should
help it but with Loki I think what's
hurting Loki is how poorly secret
Invasion did specifically the finale
because if you think about it that was
the last Taste of Marvel a lot of fans
have going into Loki season 1 so people
who
like are casual fans if they're if they
see Loki season 2's coming out and
they're like well the
finale of secret Invasion sucked I don't
really want to go into Marvel because
they're kind of bad right now like yeah
that that can affect it a
lot hey Jason yeah of course man I
remember you yeah have any idea about
getting Hugh Jackman autograph oof
uh this is what I would do as a
fan I
would I'm trying to think of how you
could do
this I would find
out who Hugh Jackman's manager and
publicist are and that is pretty public
information that you could search online
and I would email
them and I would you know if it's for
your daughters or you know your kids
stuff like that I would say hey yeah I I
I'm I'm just kind of searching
for something from Hugh Jackman may be
an autograph blah blah blah our family
loves him he's a big part of our life
you know I'm a single dad etc etc uh
I've heard people do that that and then
act and then actors sometimes send stuff
right or their their team will send them
something like that that's what I would
do
um I don't have any connections so I I
wish I could help you there um Hugh
Jackman's one of my favorites and I I I
really do want to uh I really want to
meet him I don't know if I can for
Deadpool maybe but yeah we'll
see all right hey uh 3 minutes 3 minutes
3 minutes so if you got to use the
bathroom you got to do all that go do it
now I'm going to cough real quick
sorry there we go
sorry I'm
ready yeah same Wolverine is my
childhood I
mean for the most part so like I feel
you on that one yeah I I feel you on
that one I've been
um thinking in my head how I can try to
meet him at the premiere of Deadpool 3
granted I'm invited because you never
know sometimes
so
yeah uh I don't know how to say your
name g fbx blah hgv
uh I you know I've I've
gone back and forth of covering other
content
um what I like to in the future yes
here's my issue I I'm I know I'm an
expert on
Marvel I know what I'm talking about I
have full confidence in myself and I and
I don't like that's why I don't cover
Star Wars Star Wars
actually I can't tell you how much I of
Star Wars I really do I love the lore of
Star Wars maybe more than anything out
there to be quite
honest but I'm not expert in it so I
don't really cover it
because you know people should
get their info from experts I I feel
like you know from people who really
know what they're talking about so I
stick with Marvel but um maybe in the
future you know I can dive into some
other stuff and start doing it I would
like to do that you know so hey welcome
Dennis welcome everybody
uh all right so we have one
minute and it's about to go down and I'm
going to have to figure out how to how
to do
this so I'm gonna put this here I'm
gonna
put this over here no wait that's not
how I did it last time it's I did it
like this put that here put this
here put this here
stopwatch pull this up here pull this up
here one
minute make sure you're GNA get my chat
pulled up right
here all right let's take a look see
here is it
out all right it's out
1893 let me see what I can do this
here pop out the new window window you
we're gonna open that I'm gonna start
it we're gonna
do
now it's hold on because it's
uh it's paused for me it did this
before it's not working hold
on
all right we're moving it's
working okay we're watching the recap
right now let me see if I can uh get
this going on here how do
I there we go okay
so put that
there and so here I uh we're watching
the recap right now
let's do
it this episode I like it a lot all
right hold on I got to make it to where
I have like everything set up so I can
do my chat everything like
that like a water here we go water
bottle hell yeah for Loki there we go
yeah galaxy Geeks yeah go get your
reaction yeah you obviously can't watch
it here I'll see you thanks for stopping
by got this port here this port here got
oh I stopped it no keep going there we
go all right the timer is accurate this
is this this intro right here this intro
is so
cool
D this is where at right now oh no I
stopped
[Music]
that this is really cool intro
right
here we
go yeah the music the the music in the
begin is awes all right so this one's
really interesting this is like this
kind of confused me a bit but I answer
this in my video that's I'm going to
release after this episode is uh
chump
bye
uel you're in a castle wanding Seth geez
that's cool I love me some
castles is that accurate timing two
minutes yep that's accurate
timing all right so she's meeting Miss
minutes right
now the
realist no Christian I do not have an
only
fans
this is so interesting like this is an
interesting
part he's
dead yeah that's gonna that's going to
be why that's going to help her blend in
more right the floating clock ghost is
all people would
see see you
Sean look at this this is so interesting
how they do this
guess what guess what it is can anybody
guess what it is anyone guess what she
threw through the
window I I couldn't guess makes sense
but a
TVA official
handbook this music right here is super
cool super
intense very
ominous I love
it muffin ner Muffin Man uh I don't know
the the mods must have done that maybe I
maybe if you
spammed what's up Malik what's going
on Kid K I do a video talking about this
that I'm releasing after this episode
comes out
he's asking a question we can hack it to
the
system we're all gonna die
still yeah Jason I I love that
music nothing Malik just watch and see
episode
three
Miss minutes ain't gonna help y'all
y'all need to figure something else to
do this room is great too like I love
how oh no oh
no there we go I I love how that room is
the blast doors and
everything this episode gets kind of
creepy too I
think 18 what she say 68
1893 she went there to give him the
handbook of the TVA and he is literally
right behind y'all and y'all don't even
know that window is open and she threw
the book through
there yeah Star Wars collector I really
would I
would World
Fair
hot air
balloons Hello Mickey Mick what's up
what's up Ogo Parker what's up uh
TVA that's all that's all you got to
know TVA that's how they change clothes
so quick plus L's
magic he start by
looking it's good scenes that they have
here I really like
it ghost clock continues to haunt
everyone I like that ghost
clock what time is it here it's 7:09
where I
live ghost clock so she's been she's
been
there
so she's not keeping very
low oh there's a
funny Statue
thing exactly Mr Anderson they went to
one point in time to give young Victor
timley the book and then went forward in
time to meet him when he
was 30
something not sure how old he was when
he was a
kid
this is this part right here is
funny these
statues this part this has to be a
[Laughter]
joke completely
inaccurate it's
embarrassing
Thor Odin Baler balder the
brave no one's even heard of
him you are one of them you're a Norse
god blows my mind oh and then this
intense music right
here that was not that
tall
gosh you love Loki man love
Loki uh Victor timely's astounding
temporal
Marvels pun intended
right
it's a good idea Malik but I I'm so busy
man I don't think I I don't think I have
time to do that
unfortunately this is where things start
to
get
cool I'm curious to see what everyone
thinks of Victor timley though I I will
say this Jonathan Majors can freaking
act he can act like
yeah right she's like stay in the dang
bag like you can't pop out she's like a
little like a dog or
something all right so they found RN
Slayer no it's not me Muhammad I'm
really sorry it's just people lying I
gota I'm trying to figure out how to
they just keep making new accounts I
keep Banning them but I'm sorry let be
quiet for this
part we're right here watching Victor
timely how he talks is very
interesting
very interesting way to play the
character that in that look how scared
look he is it's
him he
remains mobus is like
what I love Loki's like he is he
is yeah Ogo you're going to like this
because it's all about Victor Tom this
episode is all about Victor
timely what would you know about the
future
boy more than
you might think I love how he pauses
there
Tesla Majors that's
funny tial Loom
which is what the TVA
has
[Laughter]
power Professor snake Vibes that's
funny
voltage
look at him freaking move chaos chaos
chaos love
it he does have a stutter that's why I'm
saying it's a very interesting take on
the character curious to see what
everyone thinks of him by the
end hi this part don't misunderstand me
sir
don't want to light a
city this part's
cool to
power the entire
planet I like this
line
if it can be
dreamed it can be
achieved all science is
fiction
until it's fact love
it love
it Mobius is like Mobius is like amazing
you can't trust a variant of he who
remains in the
TVA yes the loom Loki duh the whole
point iron like show I don't know I hope
he shows up somewhere it'd be a shame if
he didn't maybe in secret Wars he just
appears as one of the heroes trying to
help I I don't
know keep in mind this is just one
variant
a
partnership I don't think he likes
that that guy just seems slimy the way
he talks the way his eyes
are I don't do partners
guy's mouth is
dropped he stands up and just give me
some
bids
gosh that facial hair like why did
people do
that yeah no I I think Maj is an
incredible actor I
I I think he's crushing
can you imagine how much $1,000 do was
back
then then Loki hits this big old
guy this big old
guy oh this part I like he goes up to
the guy gives him a little money kind of
like a sorry I couldn't give you the
machine and this is kind of how I'm like
I actually think this could be a good
variant of King right right I don't
think this I don't think this guy goes
on to be king I think he's just a good
variant he'll be all he is meant to
become but I don't think this this isn't
the origin of he who remains this is a
completely different variant living a
completely different life remember he
who remains he was in the 31st Century
not the 1900s so this is a completely
different path Loki
just amazing Loki he's not magic I
swear that's funny just makes him
disappear
they're interacting
now old friend colleague
really no this is not his origin yeah he
who remains the first variant remember
existed in the 31st
century so this is like a completely
different just you know is a random
variant that happened to appear in in
the 1900s 1800s you
know but remember he who remains is from
the year
3000s my ideas are ahead of their time
why wouldn't they be I love how he looks
at Loki after he says
that
enlightened fellows never
[Laughter]
do he ConEd
him yeah dar
dar that's one thing I had to wrap my
head around I had to really think about
about it when I first watched this I I
literally just sat there and was like
how does this make
sense and that's and that's just the
explanation is that you know variants
can appear at different points in time
but the OG Nathaniel Richards who
becomes Kang is from the 31st century
and in Loki in the Loki season 1 finale
he explained he's like eon's AO in the
future in the 31st Century you know our
variant and myself so yeah
this is a completely different origin
than he who
remains oh yeah this other temp pad
reading who is it
oh look who it
is gets
intense uh Chad's in the comics yes but
not in the MCU they clearly changed it
i' kill
him sylv still doesn't get it the TVA is
necessary to preserve the
Multiverse in a peaceful
way I love this
though because Loki was right dude come
on Ren Slayer you're so dumb
uh you gota watch on Disney
plus uh don't trip you gota watch on
Disney
plus it is intense right yeah I love
it
then don't kill
him yes thank you Ogo thank you for
explaining
that he's just now realizing that
they're from the
TVA
Loki pulls him down from Sylvie holding
him
up
L is pushing them both away from each
other I love
this it's just like the
finale
[Music]
no
where we watching it on uh Disney
plus you better
[Laughter]
run
it's C on you
Sylvie he's got he's got the two-seater
bike absolutely not you just hear Miss
minutes in the back wo just
laughing
Miss minutes is like Miss minutes has a
good story arc too you'll
see minutes don't like
that
refrigerator chair a man ahead of his
[Laughter]
time
Bravo a bit
creepy
you're
helper Madame Melle
minutes you are absolutely singular I
love
it it's high
time someone told me exactly what is
going
on a long time ago far from now it's
like Star Wars long time ago in a galaxy
far away in the
future
see see The Rebirth of countless
different versions of you so he is a
very much a different version of he who
remains this is not he who remains his
origin I love that this is like the
story of myself that I always imagined
is
true did you hear the murder
part she's got her hands on
him and Miss Menace don't like
it
Miss
ravona yeah Mr Anderson I I really like
Jonathan major I really hope he's
innocent in his
case uh I don't know don't trip just
keep trying to refresh it and make sure
you're clicking on season two
try different browsers too like uh
Chrome whatever the new Explorer called
I never
remember oh this part they can't be
trusted why
not Loki helped uh murder your
variant Loki switches sides it's a Well
documented behavioral
trait
well I'm not going anywhere till I get
my latest
prototype it's like the Caribbean of the
Midwest
lower taxes my Labis in Wisconsin lower
taxes L track US
[Music]
run
mopus is like go
ahead take him he's all yours that's
funny Rebel yeah it's it's so good man
it's Loki is just
amazing uh don't trip I would keep
refreshing because I I feel like it
should be
out
uh oh fision works I'm not sure man I
think it might be like $12 maybe 12 to15
now I think it is still a little bit I
think it's a little I think you can get
like Hulu and Disney Plus for like 15
bucks or
something use your
legs
we need the
usual he I like how he says that to the
person so he's done this before you
know yeah Jason and it gets even
better I know I like that he's like like
a grifter right but he's not necessarily
he's not bad and we're we're about to
kind of get into
that it's so interesting he's like it's
delivered to me when I was a child but
to Rana it was like 10 minutes ago for
her
gosh Miss minutes is
creepy I never found out who but now he
did
this book has defined the course of my
life and the author Ora
buros
I knew my ideas were good I just didn't
have the
technology to make them really
work
I'm starting to see the man you'll
become
if you guys have finished it we haven't
finished it yet so let's not put
spoilers in the
chat oh you're right Jason yeah it
really is this part gets really
interesting
Partners
[__] you had to do
it uh Darth Benji there's been somebody
created a fake account of mine and been
spamming
people don't give them any information
I'm sorry it's fake unfortunately I'm
working with YouTube to try to get rid
of these people but I just keep making
new accounts it's it's unfortunate I'm
I'm
sorry I'm hearing what am I hear I'm
hearing double what's going on oh this
is need to mute
myself oh is it Jose is it crashing oh
dang have a see have a
float yeah wait till next episode The
Star Wars collector I think next episode
is probably the best I've seen so
far uh fishion Works uh they just
weren't happy with it it's pretty simple
they're kind of starting
over this is
it the culmination of my life's
work and that's another reason why you
know the the other Richards was born in
the 31st Century he had the technology
to to control time and time travel this
this Victor timely variant didn't
it yeah exactly the the inedible Hulk uh
I I'm going to mention that in a
breakdown I do after I I really talk
about his kind of origin Victor tomy's
Varian origin is completely different
than he
remains
hey what's going on superhero bzs what's
going on buddy uh no and yes I don't
think we'll get it till maybe Deadpool
3 maybe Deadpool
3 not
yet
uh yes I have Deadpool I have seen that
and it's pretty
epic and Ogo Parker no I I don't know
about that because I've seen them on her
so I don't know if that means
anything
the war the TVA the eons after eons like
a million or a billion
years why didn't you allow me a real
body that wasn't
me this is where it gets
interesting if I had a body we could
lead together she she wants
him uh f i some people have said like
one or two people said that but
everybody else can hear me fine so maybe
it's in your settings or
something isn't that creepy your
girl
or a team you need me I love
you lovers
Tiff
uhoh look an original TVA time prune
stick quite unstable
I made a mistake leaving you
behind they're they're start they're
they're starting to realize now like
this isn't he who remains this is just a
variant
right we clear it as a
well miss Ren
Slayer yeah she is
Ty and he's done
o ravona and she and he called her vau
that's
interesting how dare you lecture
me right Mr rers yeah vgh that's
interesting I had to think about it I'm
like where does Von come from like raana
runs Slayer got it that's how close they
were
[Music]
the second I left everything
crumbled
order versus chaos which is what Victor
Tomy was
saying and then look who else shows
up right on time hello
Sylvie oh love
it this is oh this part's intense I'm
just G I'm going to be quiet for a
second because this part's like super
intense I love this
part this part's so
good I haven't done
anything
that isn't
me you don't know the heart I love this
scene
I can make my own
choices and then the angle turns and the
sword's like already right NE I love
this scene and she struggles with it
because she is a variant and she knows
that they're not all the
same
I love
it
oh what a
scene uh my real name is Warren w a r r
n and leave her to
me I'm like kill her kill her just kill
her just kill her get just get it over
with get Rana out of it just kill
her but I love I just love how she's
like you know not all variants are the
same because I'm a variant and I'm very
you know I love that scene so much
that's
great uh this episode does not have a
post credit scene at least it didn't in
the screeners that I
got
each time more brutal than the
last a seat at the end of
time
love it I love this is a great shot
too she kicks him to the end of she
kicks her to the end of time and look at
his freaking corpse is just sitting
right
there uh uh muffinry man where when did
we
meet when was
that love you that's what she was going
to tell
him
I know a really big secret about
you I know a big secret about you but
it's G to make you really angry yeah I
in the screeners that I got there was no
post credit scene yeah yeah I don't see
one
here nope I don't see one and that
is let me do
this all right what did everybody think
of Loki season two episode three
because I thought it was pretty good and
guess what episode four is even better
in my own opinion
uh yeah you get to find out the secret I
it's not such a
huge deal as they make it out
to to be perfectly honest um the whole
well yeah it is like the idea behind it
all they I should say they don't make it
they're not like this is the secret bomb
dropped they just kind of like say what
it is and continue on so yeah yeah isn't
isn't Miss minutes creepy she is creepy
right I love it she's
awesome 3 two one really I'm I think I'm
kind of like a three h I think I might
be a 132 or a
312 type of
[Laughter]
guy let me see this needed to check
something
oh now you show it
stupid there we go yeah
um I let's go ahead I see people doing
it rate the episode please uh rate it
rate it rate it let's do you know one
out of 10 10 out of 10 being the best uh
Jack got games 10 out of 10 muffin
muffin man 10 10 Ogo Parker 1010 Jason
coming in with 11 out of 10 love it
scuff what you doing
10 Ty you think this is just you think
it's better than season one awesome love
it oh so do you Andrew okay
okay uh Oho I think I think what they
were saying was episode three is their
favorite then episode two then episode
one's their favorite Deontay 10 derka
one you didn't really like
it everan eight Aaron eight Mr Anderson
10 for sure Gareth 10
uh thuka 9.9 out of 10 what where's the
where's the0
one why why the missing point1 why uh
why isn't 10 out of 10 for you I'm uh
I'm curious Matthew
8 Leon what wait she is his
daughter oh you're talking oh the secret
the secret the secret I I'm keeping my
mouth shut on the secret I do know the
secret I'm keeping my mouth shut sorry
I'm not going to say anything Kevin 13
out of 10 love it already better than
season one for you too Thea that's
awesome Ty you say the same arshad uh 10
out of 10 okay okay okay I love it so
everyone's loving it so far it's it's a
awesome Andrew really you think it's a
slower episode than episode uh two
because I think episode two was slower
actually will will Andrews nine out of
how do you tip me for my efforts oh
you're talking about super chats uh you
can super chat if you want I appreciate
that but just you know being in the chat
I appreciate that as well and I
appreciate everybody just watching hint
on the secret uh you've heard it already
actually and that's all I'll
say love season one this so effing good
love
it you feel like you're gonna see
Ant-Man by the season finale Elite I
don't know I don't know I haven't seen
episodes five and
six I feel like we should see like
Deadpool
right did Loki Mobius And Timely go back
to the TV at the end Deontay yes they
did Matt D nine out of 10 wish there was
more World building instead of antics
you know what I feel you on that because
that's kind of how I felt I felt
like I love it I got I just I love it
but I want to know how it affects
everything overall that's what I can't
wait to
see Nathan 10 out of 10 love Jonathan
major Victor timely he made the episode
for me like okay I know Jonathan M is
going through all this stuff right now I
hope he's innocent I believe he's
innocent based off of the the evidence
I've
seen phenomenal actor though
like you can't really deny it like he's
he's to me the the Loki season one
finale he was so
good and and and the the parts name in
in the was quantam Mania where you see
him as Kang are so intense and he he's a
great
actor that's funny Mr Anderson Disney
started suggesting Miss Marvel instead
of secret Invasion now obviously they
they're C they're catching on oh my gosh
Ogo thank you so much youd have to do
that I super appreciate that no you're
too kind thank you so much thanks for
popping in and contributing and uh
adding into the conversation I really
appreciate that thank you so much thank
you thank you thank
you I particularly don't like to give
some 10 out 10 because I like to think
next few episodes are even better I
think episode 10 or 10 gez episode
4 I think episode four is the best I
don't know I don't want to like overhype
it right because then that's how people
are like oh you overhyped it but I I I
there's there's like there's a part in
episode 4 where I literally yelled I
literally so this is all I'll say
there's a part episode 4 when I was
literally like I was like I really
was yeah
I it's a great episode this series is
great Loki season one's my favorite you
know favorite I I guess I I should just
say Loki the series season one anti are
my favorite like I just
just it's and it's it's it's everything
it's everything from
Tom Heston and and Owen Wilson's
chemistry together the other amazing
supporting characters like Sylvie and
she's not suppor she's a main character
but you know the the the intricate
relationship between Loki and Sylvie
where they like love each other but they
are each other you know and then you add
in like he who remains and then you add
in like the
ominous feeling that you get and the
like that that's a combination like the
background music and like the set
and and the tones like that you that you
physically see and then the tones you
hear just overall Loki to me is just
it's such a
perfect series just season one and
season like I I love
it I love it I I can't wait to say what
it ends I I I hope they just I just
really hope they they nail it with the
ending man I hope they nail
it oh Mr Anderson what is that's that's
something I'm really looking forward to
right seeing Mobius interact with
Deadpool Wade yeah same Ogo I just love
Loki man like like man he's so
cool Kelly Thompson 10 out of 10 awesome
love it Adon greetings from Honduras
hello greetings
back uh Billy Bug entertainment that's
interesting maybe see Tera strong live
action appearance of Miss minutes maybe
who who who knows who knows is timely
villain villain you're confused I don't
think he
is I made a video and I want to keep
reminding people that when I make I made
my videos and breakdowns before I saw
episode 4 so yes I know what happens in
episode 4 but I did
not watch episode 4 before I did my
breakdown for
episode three and I'm going to release a
bunch of videos about episode 3 The that
you're going to see and as soon as I get
off my live stream and I I put it up
it's very specific video it's not a full
breakdown but it's explaining a few
things one is the origin of Victor
timley because this is not the same
origin as Victor timley from the comics
this isn't a Nathaniel Richards AKA Kang
who discovered time travel in the 31st
Century went back to ancient Egypt
became ramut got time displaced and then
went back to Earth and in you know in
the 18 1800 1900s that's not this is not
that story he who remains is from the
31st Century he was born there he he
developed everything there and then when
the Multiverse broke out variant started
appearing at different points in time
Victor Tomy is a very different very
different variant than he remains they
are not the same they do not have the
same ordin they
don't what if he did make a body for
Miss minut minutes and it's LOL Leon
that's funny thanks for being a member
man appreciate that
um that would be funny um maybe I
mean it it wouldn't be the craziest
thing we've seen happen in Marvel would
it
so uh I see timely is a genuinely good
guy but as long as he keeps seeing what
we will achieve or he supposed to become
he will become evil I don't know because
so here's here's
um here's what I noticed in me watching
and like picking up
uh
uh in watching this when he is taking
bids for the the fake machine that he
built
um he takes you know ultimately takes
1,000 bucks but the other guy who
offered him 500 and 600 and then I think
it's like 650 or 7 750
he gives him some
money after like he goes up to him he's
at the bar the guy's sad and then he and
then victor goes up to him puts some
money secretly under his hat Pats him on
the shoulder and it's like showing that
like he's genuinely like sorry he's like
I'm sorry but at the same time he
shouldn't be sorry because he was
grifting so it's like you
know I don't
know uh raana is the
romantic love interest of Victor of
Victor Tim of Kang in the comics he he
loves her she loves
him I gotta check on one thing sorry I
am
tired okay cool that's
there cool so
yes um I'm trying to to think was one of
the guys actually someone portraying as
Tomas Edison he did mention Thomas
Edison in
there but I don't I don't
know if they were actually
him just yeah uh I can't
uh maybe Lord of hunger maybe that guy
was trying to help him out that's a
that's actually a good way to look at it
you could be right right there you
actually could
yeah I have a very I have a very
interesting
theory that I don't necessarily want to
be
right but I think it could be
right
but so the theory that I I'm putting out
this Theory as soon as I get the live
stream I have the video ready to go um I
just got to kind of fill fill out some
stuff for
it and I it makes sense is the thing
like I just I started thinking about
it and I was
like I I I I thought it could be
possible but then when I really dove
into this
episode I was like oh it's really
possible actually
like really possible so it's I'm like I
don't know but you'll see because it's
gonna it's in my next video that I'm
putting out uh like whenever I get off
the stream I'm I'm basically gonna go
put it out hey Leon thanks for that
Super Chat thank you very much thanks
for being here
um did I get rid of the Loki coffee I
did
not I think i' put it back in the box
and it's in my closet right
now uh
you need Matt put it up now you need
something after this I gotta get off I
gota get off the stream because I gotta
like fill out all the the description
and everything like that put up the tags
and stuff like that so I'm uh I can't
release it this second um I am a little
sick though my voice is starting to give
out so we are gonna kind of wrap up the
stream here John Carlo n out of 10 love
it love it love it love love
it were you able to tree the whole show
before us or was only the first four
episodes uh yeah uh just the first four
episode so I have no idea five or I have
no idea how it
ends see gotcha yeah do you think Miss
Min is made from he who remains memories
of Ren
Slayer uh no but you
actually made me think that maybe they
are the the memories of he who
remains maybe he loves
himself I mean you you could be you
could be right there maybe but she did
betray Ren Slayer so I'm not not sure
about
that angel she's a variant I I'm not you
know I'm not
not I'm not saying the
secret I'm not saying the secret but um
what I will say is in the next
episode there is a moment I think
there's actually there were a few
moments where like I'm just like wow but
there was one moment where I
literally
gasped I I literally Lally I just gasped
I was
like and I think I audibly yell I was
like like like really I was
just it shocked me and there I think
there's a few parts if I recall in in
the in the next
episode like that so I'm really excited
for everyone to see the next episode if
y'all like this one I feel like you're
really going to like the next one thanks
for serson thanks for all telling me to
get better uh yeah I thank you thank you
thank you thank you appreciate it
appreciate it appreciate it um you guys
have got a lot of good theories about
what the secret
is
um I'm not g say
anything thank you oo I appreciate that
thank you for that super chat again I
really really do appreciate that I
appreciate you all um chatting really
really do really really do tell if
that's how you pronounce your name Miss
men and raon both varant remains yeah I
H I I I had those thoughts too um and I
can honestly say that I I'm not sure
because I haven't seen episode five or
six I'm not sure but raana in the comics
is not a variant of King she is who he
actually loves so yeah miss m is raana
be interesting right it's like
her ogus said that I think yeah it's be
if that's like her it is her memories or
something like you know uploaded somehow
so we'll see it we'll see that's what it
is raana is misto I'm going back to that
part where where Mobius called her vau
for raana that just shows you how close
they are I didn't catch that until this
time because I was watching with the
captions this time I um when you get the
screeners we we can't put the captions
on there's no option for that so but all
right y'all I am uh gota put this video
out so like it should be out in like 10
minutes 10 1015 minutes wait hold on let
me just have a copyright or something
like that let me see if something would
put me
behind nope it looks good to go it is
uploaded it is edited and I just got to
do like the description and upload my
thumbnail and it's going to be good to
go so look out for my video uh it'll be
out I'm gonna say 10 to 20 minutes so uh
so yeah thank you all for stopping by
today thank you to everybody who super
chatted I really really do appreciate
that and to the people who are just
chatting appreciate y'all and even if
you were just watching thank you for
being here you could have been anywhere
else but you're here so thank you very
much uh look forward to next episode
because it is fantastic my personal
opinion I think if everybody liked this
episode they'll really like the next one
and um there's really cool interactions
the next episode really really cool with
everyone on TV it's like super cool so
everybody have a great night thank you
for being here and uh look up for my
video